our wounds run deep and I know many of
you are afraid of what threats tomorrow
may bring but the flash doesn't just
protect us he restores hope where it was
lost that's why I'm honored to present
the key to the man who saved central
city the flash
the doors to Central City will forever
be open for you flash
couple background yeah
I was late again it wasn't I right on
time
you
hey youtubers is Charlie so new footage
from the flash episode one kind of gives
you an idea for the tone of the show
when things pick up remember it's been a
while since the end of season 1
I'm sure Oliver Queen would be super
bummed out to see how much central city
is embracing the flash compared to the
way Starling city treated the arrow last
year they absolutely hated him by the
end of season 3 despite the fact that he
saved the city as you can see from
Barry's face though he's actually a
little bit surprised to be receiving all
this attention he's a little melancholy
because technically Eddie is the person
that saved the city at the end of season
1 remember if he hadn't have committed
suicide then the reverse-flash would
have been able to kill Barry just
completely nullifying anything that they
were trying to do I have a few minor
issues with the way that story ended
like the way they used that
reverse-flash character but Tom Cavanagh
is coming back as an earth 2 character
he's gonna be like the earth 2 version
of Harrison wells and that's also like
the character that we meet in this
episode the villain is gonna be atom
smasher whenever we first found this out
it was kind of weird because obviously
the flash was fighting him and it's like
well atom smashers is a good character
he's part of Justice Society in the
comics why is the flash fighting him why
is he bad well it turns out this is the
earth to atom smasher and earth to atom
smasher is only trying to get the flash
because zoom told him that he would help
him get back to earth too if he killed
Barry Allen and we actually have seen
better footage of zoom I mean it's like
been very brief and it's kind of fuzzy
but you get the idea this is kind of
what the costume is gonna look like this
might change by the series finale
usually the special effects get better
and better with each episode like even
the flash costume that Grant Gustin wore
change from the beginning of the season
to the end of the season
like they just they made it easier for
him to take off like he wasn't able to
turn his neck with the first version of
the costume they wore but the other
stuff that's going on here is that
Martin Stein is still like a big
presence and team flash I'm guessing
that he's kind of filled the hole that
Harrison wells of earth one has left as
far as I know Caitlin snow is actually
running STAR Labs though like she'll be
the person responsible for hiring people
they've got at least one new character I
know that they're going to be hiring on
so like the STAR Labs team will grow and
then you have people like Joe and iris
that have like big storylines to take
place outside of STAR Labs really like
the three big places where they surface
stories are gonna be the police station
you know via Joe West and his metahuman
task force STAR Labs with team flash and
then the newspaper or the the news
however you want to think about it we
know wherever iris works there been a
couple promos that have teased the flash
running all over the world so I'm
wondering if her coverage of the flash
is gonna go national and she'll start
helping team flash in that way that's
really her scale working in and around
the news I'm also kind of thinking that
like a big part of her storyline is
gonna deal with wally west cuz obviously
somehow he is going to be related to her
whether he's some secret brother she
didn't know about or he's from earth-2
there's still like a lot of wally west
stuff that we don't know he hasn't
appeared in any of these clips Candice
Patton actually did say some interesting
stuff she said that we would see three
flashes this season obviously we've seen
Jay Garrick so he's number two but I
think the third one is probably gonna
end up being Wally West I'm really
hoping for a female speedster but you
guys let me know in the comments who do
you think this third flash is going to
be is gonna be Wally West or is it gonna
be one of the female speedsters that
they just haven't given powers to on the
show yet I think we have just a quick
coming on like even iris West got flash
powers for a brief period in the comics
patty spivot also a speedster there's
also this really interesting promo
poster to consider they might just be
messing with us a little bit here but it
looks like there's speed force just like
kind of rising off of Barry Allen now in
the comics Wally West was actually able
to grant and take Speed Force from other
speedsters to make himself faster or
slower so I'm wondering if between like
these you know three flashes we're gonna
see people transferring Speed Force
powers and actually it's time to name a
new winner of the reverse flash ring
giveaway so congratulations Holly's
crafts be sure to private message me on
the back end of my channel I'll arrange
for you to get the gift certificate so
you can just order it to wherever you
live there'll be at least like two or
three flash rings I'll give away this
week I'll probably double the giveaway
for the premiere there's a whole bunch
of new characters coming in the comics
I've already done a couple videos on
some of their origins but I'll try to do
like a quick explainer for who they are
whenever they show up be sure to
subscribe to get everything and I will
be live tweeting the premiere tomorrow
so if you want to follow me on Twitter
there's a link at the bottom of the
description for that too but I'll also
put some bonus links in the description
if you guys want to hear about like
certain specific characters so while you
guys wait for everything you can click
here for all my arrow and flash trailer
videos and you can click here to catch
up on Gotham I'll try to get that video
out tonight too so thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight